i've been very careful when we've been
talking about george w
bush during the donald trump era not to
participate in the rehabilitation of
george w
bush's image and this is one of the
dangers of not
talking about former presidents which we
discussed a few weeks ago which is
they end up being allowed either
implicitly or explicitly to sort of
rewrite their own history and legacy as
president of the united states
in george w bush's case his legacy is
not taking the 911 threat seriously
enough to start with
more importantly reacting to the 9 11
attacks by invading
a country that didn't do it the country
of iraq
declaring mission accomplished years
early
staying in a total quagmire of a
situation while hemorrhaging money
and blowing up the deficit all to get us
nothing
while committing war crimes that's a bad
legacy
and i haven't even mentioned the bush
administration's response to hurricane
katrina which is another complete and
total fiasco
and yes at the same time as an
individual
compared to donald trump bush is less
wacky
he's less obviously unhinged he sounds
more reasonable he seems to relate to
people
just on an individual level in a more
normal way than donald trump
but george w bush has partially rehabbed
his image
by becoming friends with michelle obama
and by being friends with ellen
degeneres and
painting portraits of veterans and now
he's sort of like a friendly older past
president who just wants everybody to
get along so the point is
i've been careful when we say wow even
george w bush realizes that this thing
trump did or that thing trump did is
terrible
to understand the context of the
horrible legacy of george w bush now
that gets us to this morning
this morning george w bush appeared on
the today show
and he actually laid out a pretty cogent
case against the direction of the modern
republican party
since bush left office through the obama
administration
and during donald trump's one-term
presidency
and he is completely correct he arguably
doesn't even go far enough let's listen
and then we'll talk about it uh i would
describe it as
isolationist protectionist and to a
certain extent nativist
are you disappointed well it's not
exactly my vision
yeah but you know what i'm just an old
guy they put out the pasture so
just a simple painter it's a simple
painter so let's take this in pieces i
mean first of all
is what george w bush is saying correct
it is correct the republican party has
gone
since bush left more fully to the
i don't even know that i'd call it
isolationism and protectionism i'd call
it
nationalism and yes nativism and even
nativism doesn't really go far enough
it's really more
it's almost like a xenophobia that's
very popular in white nationalist
circles it goes beyond nativist so bush
is right and
he probably doesn't go far enough now it
is
true or better said is it true that this
is not bush's vision for the party as he
says
and that it wasn't bush's vision when he
was president well
yes sort of but the truth is more
complicated it's not
the republican party has now gone
nativist xenophobe
and bush wasn't at all that when he was
president of the united states
the reality is that bush's gop
was maybe more indifferent to the
nativism
and they played coy with the nativism
and while they were less
cartoonishly talking about it in the way
trump did
they allowed it and they even had many
people that were part of the
administration that were very much
of that mindset bush personally like is
bush personally a nativist xenophobe
like what he now criticizes about the
republican party
probably not i don't really know but
it's sort of like is trump personally
anti-semitic
we talked before well you know trump has
a jewish daughter by conversion ivanka
and his son-in-law jared kushner
and trump has jewish grandkids and all
this stuff
doesn't really matter trump coalesced
the anti-semites
so his personal view isn't super
relevant to me whatever george w
bush's personal view of the nativist
xenophobic wing of the republican party
is
bush's presidency certainly didn't call
out that wing of the republican party
and it allowed that wing to grow into
what it became during obama and
ultimately
led to donald trump so with all of these
issues it's more complicated than what
bush believes
and it's more nuanced than bush wasn't
at all
on the isolationist nativist gop side
it's more like bush probably calculated
that the republican party was going in
that direction even if it wasn't his
thing
he found a way to placate that wing
without being as cartoonishly welcoming
of it as donald trump
was so what this gets us to is like how
should we react when george w
bush criticizes trump and now is
criticizing the modern republican party
is bush a hero
for calling it out or is he a foe who's
pretending not to have been a part of it
neither life is more complicated it's
not always black and white
the reaction for me is bush was a
disaster
but even bush realizes that the
republican party since him
and under trump is an even bigger
disaster
but he's also partially responsible for
it they all are right i mean
you know what the the right during the
civil rights era
into the vietnam era into reagan
into gingrich and then so on into bush
right i mean
it's all part of what got that party to
what it is today
and you don't have to praise george w
bush to realize that
but you can also recognize the role that
he either implicitly or explicitly or by
negligence had
in getting the party to where it is
today that being said
it's i i i wonder how much of the modern
republican electorate
which is mostly behind donald trump
cares what george w bush says at this
point in time i don't know the answer to
that
remains to be seen really excited that
uh one of our sponsors today
is helix sleep i sleep on a helix
mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video